Hi! This video is focused on the /t/ sound.
/t/ is a plosive voiceless consonant sound.
And that means that there's a lot of energy behind the sound.
The /t/ sound is produced by bringing the tip of your tongue to your gum ridge and releasing it...
...like this, /t/.
A common challenge in making this sound is when the speaker uses the blade of the tongue...
...or the top of the tongue and presses it against the front of the teeth.
This creates a very splashy /t/ sound.
Here is a splashy version, /t/ /t/.
And here is a precise version, /t/ /t/.
Let's practice together.
One of my favorite ways to find the correct placement for the /t/ sound requires a prop.
So please grab a chopstick so you can do this exercise along with me.
First, scratch the tip of your tongue and then press up on the gum ridge....
...on the exact spot that you want the tip to hit.
And now let's do a few tongue ups together.
The purpose of this exercise is to recondition your tongue to go to the specific placement for the /t/ sound.
Here we go.
Tip, release.
Make sure that your jaw stays released and the tongue is doing the work.
Try this at least ten times.
Now let's try a few words together.
Tell.
Tea.
Tap.
Sitting.
Batter.
Writer.
Cast.
Cute.
Part.
And a little tongue twister for fun,...
...tea for two and two for tea.
Tea for two and two for tea.
Try this out as you practice on EnglishCentral and good luck!